do you think we will ever build a system
of human level or superhuman level
intelligence we've kind of defined what
it takes to try to approach that but do
you think we'll do you think that's
within our reach the thing that we
thought we could do what touring thought
actually we could do by a year 2000
right do you think we'll ever be able to
do so I think that two answers here one
question one answer is in principle can
we do this at some time and my answer is
yes the second answer is a pragmatic one
do you think we will be able to do it in
the next 20 years or whatever and - that
man says no so of course that's a wild
guess I I think that you know Donald
Rumsfeld is not a favorite person of
mine but one of his lines was very good
which is about known knowns known
unknowns and unknown unknowns so in the
business we are in there are known
unknowns and we have unknown unknowns so
I think with respect to a lot of what
the case in vision and robotics I feel
like we have known unknowns so I have a
sense of where we need to go and what
the problems that need to be solved are
I feel with respect to natural language
understanding and high-level cognition
it's not just known unknowns but also
unknown unknowns so it is very difficult
to put any kind of a timeframe to that
do you think some of the unknown
unknowns might be positive in that
they'll surprises and make the job much
easier so fundamental breakthroughs I
think that is possible because certainly
I have been very positively surprised by
how effective these deep learning
systems have been because I certainly
would not have believed that in 2010
I think what we knew from the
mathematical theory was that convex
optimization works when there is a
single global Optima then this gradient
descent techniques would work now these
are non linear systems with non convex
systems huge number of variables over
amortized over parametrized and the
people who is to play with them a lot
the ones who are totally immersed in the
Lord and the black magic
they knew that they worked well even
though they were really I thought like
everybody know that claim that I hear
from my friends like young lacunae and
so forth in now yeah that they feel that
they were comfortable with it well he
says well the community as a whole was
certainly not and I think we were to me
that was the surprise that they actually
worked robustly for a wide range of
problems from a wide range of
initializations and so on and so that
was that was certainly more rapid
progress than we expected but then there
are certainly lots of times in fact most
of the history of AI is when we have
made less proud progress at a slower
rate than we expected so we just keep
going I think what I regard is really
unwarranted are these these fears of you
know AGI in ten years and 20 years and
that kind of stuff because that's based
on completely unrealistic models of how
rapidly we will make progress in this
field so I agree with you but I've also
gotten a chance to interact with very
smart people who really worried about
existential threats of AI and I as an
open-minded person I'm sort of taking it
and taking it in do you think if AI
systems
in some way the unknown unknowns not
super intelligent yeah but in ways we
don't quite understand the nature of
super intelligence will have a
detrimental effect on society do you
think this is something we should be
worried about or we need to first allow
the unknown unknowns to become known
unknowns I think we need to be worried
about air today I think that it is not
just a worry we need to have when we get
that AGI I think that AI is being used
in many systems today and there might be
settings for example when it causes
biases or decisions which could be
harmful so I mean decisions which could
be unfair to some people or it could be
a self-driving cars which kills a
pedestrian so AI systems are being
deployed today right and they are being
deployed in many different settings may
be in medical diagnosis may be in a
self-driving car may be in selecting
applicants for an interview so I would
argue that when these systems make
mistakes there are consequences and we
are in a certain sense responsible for
those consequences and so I would argue
that this is a continuous effort it is
we and and this is something that in a
way is not so surprising it's about all
engineering and scientific progress
which great power comes great
responsibility
so as these systems are deployed we have
to worry about them and it's a
continuous problem I don't think of it
as something which will suddenly happen
on some day in 2079
for which I need to design some clever
trick I am saying that these problems
exist today here and we need to be
continuously on the lookout for worrying
about safety biases risks right I mean
the self-driving car kills a pedestrian
and they have right I mean the this uber
incident in Arizona yeah right it has
happened right this is not about AGI if
in fact it's about a very dumb
intelligence
it's killing people the worry people
have with AGI is the scale and I but I
think you're a hundred percent right is
like the thing that worries me about AI
today and it's happening the huge scale
is recommend recommender system
recommendation systems so if you look at
Twitter or Facebook or YouTube they're
controlling the ideas that we have
access to the news and so on and that's
a fundamentally machine learning
algorithm behind each of these
recommendations and they I mean my life
would not be the same without these
sources of information I'm a totally new
human being and the ideas that I know
are very much because of the internet
because of the algorithms that recommend
those ideas and so as they get smarter
and smarter I mean that is the AGI yeah
is that's the the algorithm that's
recommending the next YouTube video you
should watch has control of millions of
billions of people that that algorithm
is already super intelligent and has
complete control of the population not a
complete but very strong control for now
we can turn off YouTube we can just go
have a normal life outside of that but
the more and more that gets into our
life
it's that algorithm we start depending
on it and the different companies that
are working on the algorithm so I think
it's you're right it's already it's
already there and YouTube in particular
is using computer vision doing their
hardest to try to understand the content
of video so they could be able to
connect videos with the people who would
benefit from those videos the most and
so that development could go in a bunch
of different directions some of which
might be harmful so yeah you're right
the the the threats of AI here already
we should be thinking about them
you